hey everyone did you know that Amazon
web services or AWS dominate the cloud
computing Market with a staggering 32
market share well with a wide area of
services AWS has become the go-to
platform for individuals and businesses
looking to Leverage The Power of the
cloud but what exactly are AWS services
and why are they so crucial in today's
digital landscape well to answer these
questions here we are with a new video
on AWS services so let's embark on an
exciting journey to explore the
captivating world of AWS and uncover its
numerous benefits
but before moving ahead do subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn so if you want to learn more about
cloud computing platforms Cloud
Computing Services and its various other
interesting in-depth Concepts than our
Caltech cloud computing bootcamp will be
the right choice for you this cloud
computing bootcam will help you become
an expert in Azure and AWS this in-depth
cloud computing online bootcamp course
lets you master key architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert it will help
you become an expert in designing
planning and scaling Cloud
implementations our cloud computing
course helps you master the core skill
sets required to design and deploy
dynamically scalable and reliable
obligations on Microsoft Azure and AWS
so do check out the course link
mentioned in the description now let's
start with the video well the first
thing that we are going to discuss is
what is AWS now imagine a virtual our
house that provides on-demand Computing
resources storage and other tools all
accessible over the Internet that's
precisely what AWS offers Amazon web
services is a comprehensive cloud
computing platform that enables
individuals and organizations to access
a wide range of scalable flexible and
cost effective solutions to meet their
diverse needs now the second question
that comes into my mind is what is the
need of AWS Services well in today's
fast-paced Digital World businesses are
increasingly relying on the cloud for
their operations AWS Services addressed
the growing demand for scalable
infrastructure data storage and advanced
tools without the burden of managing
physical Hardware whether you're a
startup a medium-sized business or an
Enterprise AWS provides the backbone to
innovate scale and transform now AWS
Services span a vast landscape catering
to various domains including computing
power storage databases networking
artificial intelligence and machine
learning but let's take a closer look at
some key AWS services that are
revolutionizing the way we build and
deploy applications so the first one
that we are going to come across is
Amazon elastic compute Cloud which is
also known as Amazon ec2 now Amazon ec2
offers resizable compute capacity in the
cloud allowing users to scale resources
up or down based on their requirements
it provides virtual servers known as
instances giving users full control over
their Computing environment now ec2
instances support a wide range of
operating systems and applications
making it easy to deploy and manage your
workloads second is Amazon S3 known as
Amazon simple storage service Amazon S3
is a highly scalable and secure object
storage service it offers durable
storage for data of any size accessible
from anywhere in the world now S3 is
designed to provide High availability
and low latency making it ideal for
storing and retrieving vast amounts of
data such as images videos backups and
log files additionally S3 integrates
seamlessly with other AWS Services
enabling data driven applications and
Analytics third is Amazon RDS relational
database service now Amazon RDS
simplifies the management of relational
databases by automating Common tasks
such as backups software patching and
scaling it supports popular database
engines like MySQL post GRE SQL Oracle
and SQL Server RDS provides a reliable
scalable and cost effective solution for
running your databases in the cloud
seeing you from the administrative
burdens associated with traditional
database management now next comes AWS
Lambda now AWS Lambda is a serverless
Computing service that allows you to run
your code without provisioning or
managing servers it executes functions
in response to events such as changes to
data in an S3 bucket or a new message in
a queue with Lambda you pay only for the
compute time consumed by your functions
making it highly cost effective for
running small event driven applications
or for offloading compute tasks from
traditional servers and following that
we have Amazon dynamodb now Amazon
dynamodb is a fully managed no SQL
database service that provides fast and
predictable performance at any scale it
offers seamless scalability automatic
data replication across multiple regions
and built-in security features now
dynamodb is ideal for applications that
require low latency High throughput
access to structured data such as
e-commerce platforms gaming applications
and real-time Analytics
so now that we have covered about AWS
Services let's look into its features
now AWS Services come packed with the
plethora of powerful feature designed to
enhance performance security and
reliability so let's explore some
notable features first is elastic
scalability now AWS Services allow you
to easily scale resources up or down to
match demand ensuring Optimal
Performance and cost efficiency this
elasticity ensures that your
applications can handle fluctuating
workload seamlessly
second is global infrastructure now AWS
operates in multiple regions worldwide
enabling low latency access to services
and redundancy for high availability now
this Global footprint allows you to
deploy your applications closer to your
end users reducing latency and improving
the user experience then comes security
and compliance now AWS are theres to
stringent security practices and
certifications protecting your data and
ensuring compliance with industry
regulations AWS provides robust security
features such as encryption identity
access management Network firewalls and
monitoring tools to help you secure your
applications and data then comes
Automation and management tools now AWS
provides a range of tools to simplify
infrastructure management deployment
monitoring and troubleshooting services
like AWS cloud formation AWS elastic
Beanstalk and AWS Cloud watch enable you
to automate and streamline your
operations saving time and effort so now
let's move on to the advantages of AWS
Services now embracing AWS Services
offers numerous advantages for
individuals and organizations alike
first is cost Effectiveness now AWS
follows a pay as you go pricing model
allowing you to pay only for the
resources you consume this eliminates
the need for large upfront Investments
and provide cost savings through
resource optimization now AWS is pricing
flexibility enables you to align cost
with your business needs and scale your
infrastructure as you grow
second is scalability and flexibility
AWS Services provide unmatched
scalability enabling you to easily
accommodate growing workloads and sudden
bursts in demand whether you need to
handle a seasonal surge in traffic or
rapidly scale your business AWS can
dynamically adjust resources to meet
your requirements the flexible nature of
AWS Services allows you to experiment
innovate and deploy new applications
quickly giving you a Competitive Edge
third is reliability and high
availability now AWS Global
infrastructure is designed for high
availability ensuring that your
applications and data remain accessible
and resilient even in the face of
unexpected events or disasters AWS
services are built with redundancy and
fault tolerance in mind reducing the
risk of downtime and ensuring continuous
operation for your critical systems and
the last one is access to Cutting Edge
technology well with AWS you can tap
into the latest advancements in
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data analytics AWS services like
Amazon sagemaker Amazon recognition and
Amazon redshit Empower you to unlock
valuable insights make data driven
decisions and build intelligent
applications that Leverage The Power of
AI and ml so now we have reached the
conclusion AWS services have
revolutionized The Way businesses
operate enabling them to harness the
Limitless power of the cloud with a wide
range of services robust features and
unparalleled scalability AWS offers an
unmatched ecosystem for Innovation
growth and transformation this is a
success story of one of our Learners to
boost your confidence
do watch this video
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech concept video that with this
course I had the choice to study while I
can understand that is how I got this
new job offer with 60 percent salary
high in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit of my new company
we cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are all well this was all
about AWS Services if you like this
video then please do give it a thumbs up
and do share it with your friends and if
you have any questions related to this
video then please feel free to ask away
in the comment section our team will
reach out to you as soon as possible
thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign